salut aujourd'hui on va parler du
mouvement du regard jeudi me la faire le
point avec mes yeux l'idée c'est de
parler de la détection du mensonge et
plus précisément d'une théorie en pnl
sur la direction du regard il y a une
explication donnée pour chacun des
mouvements du regard vous en avez
sûrement déjà entendu parler que ce soit
sur ma chaîne ou ailleurs en fait c'est
pas si simple il ya pas mal de
précisions apportées sur le sujet et du
coup d'autre chose sur lequel on
pourrait faire un focus vous connaissez
forcément ce schéma en pnl qui
interprète le mouvement du regard ce
schéma est remis en cause depuis
quelques années il ya des études qui
sont faites sur le sujet est-ce que tout
est bon à prendre
est-ce que tout est bon au contraire à
jeter on va en parle j'ai vécu moi-même
personnellement le syndrome de l'horloge
cassé durant quelques années le syndrome
de lowe roche cassé c'est une horloge
qui serait cassé un un petit peu mais
c'est pas ça l'explication disons qu'une
horloge cassé à l'indic deux fois par
jour là bonheur donc si on regarde leur
à ce moment là sur ces deux fois là on
va se dire balle marche très très bien
cette horloge c'est quoi le problème
mais le problème c'est que le reste du
temps elle ne fonctionne pas et donc
dire qu'elle fonctionne et faux et c'est
le cas de la fameuse théorie en pnl sur
les mouvements du regard théorie qui a
même été remis en cause par les
créateurs même de la pnl
c'est le principe même des recherches
c'est à dire qu'on remet en cause des
choses au fur et à mesure on les
réadaptant on en tire des conclusions
bonne d'à côté mauvaise de l'autre au
lieu de créer deux clans de oui c'est ça
et c'est que ça ou c'est nul ça ne
fonctionne pas et si on ne trouvait ce
qui est bon à garder ce qui est bon à
jeter le premier problème c'est que
l'analyse des mouvements du regard sont
centrées uniquement sur l'individu et ne
prend pas le contexte c'est à dire à ce
cas une porte et ce qu'on ait dollars us
qu'à une fenêtre est ce qu'il ya des
gens qui passaient ski à d'autres
personnages à pied c'est ce qui est des
ya des problèmes de luminosité peut-être
est-ce qu'on a réfléchi à l'état de la
personne si elle est mal à l'aise
peut-être qu'elle va chercher un point
de fuite avec son regard tout le
problème est là on n'implique pas le
principe de la base line je vous en ai
déjà parlé et sur la chaîne est dans le
livre la base line c'est de prendre tout
le contexte extérieur de la personne et
aussi intérieures émotionnellement en
compte si la personne est un peu les
yeux vers le passé d'un signe de
tristesse si le regard fut
l'interlocuteur c'est peut être un signe
de remords ou un signe de honte c'est la
personne détourne le regard ça peut être
un signe du dcu surtout si on met ça en
corrélation avec la micro expressions du
dégoût penser également de la
psychologie du mensonge d'un menteur a
tendance à regarder la personne dans les
yeux pour voir si la personne est en
train de gober son mensonge de
l'accepter mais le regard fixe ça peut
être aussi un signe de colère et dans le
cas du schéma basiques de la pnl les
liens entre la réalité de ces
explications et les mouvements oculaires
ont été largement démenties je voulais
dit même par les auteurs mais il reste
très ancré dans la croyance populaire
parce que c'est dur d'admettre qu'on
s'est trompé ça fait une dissonance
cognitive on n'aime pas ça alors que des
personnes se sont vraiment penchés sur
le sujet comme alain brossard en 92 qui
avait fait tout un livre sur la
psychologie du regard qui s'appelle la
psychologie qui regardent c'était pas
compliqué je vous le recommande mais
encore une fois ça sert à rien de se
positionner sur ok donc dans le mensonge
les yeux faut pas en prendre compte
qu'il faut les prenant conduire quelque
chose à voir la fréquence des
clignements des yeux encore une fois ça
ne vaut rien si on n'a pas la base line
si on sait pas comment se comporte la
personne initialement la détection s'est
cumulé plaint d' indices et voir si une
corrélation entre tous ces indices est
là à ce moment là on ne sera pas encore
sûr à 100% mais ce quel mensonge verbal
de ce qui est raconté ya aussi le
mensonge émotionnelle dans quel état
elle veut paraître
mais dans quel état elle est vraiment
d'époque il est en soi il n'existe pas
de recette miracle en disant si la
personne fait ça c'est qu'elles m'ont
fait le termine en vous parlant d'une
étude intéressante et récente qui date
de 2012 qui a été faite par des
chercheurs de l'université de portsmouth
ils ont fait deux protocoles
expérimentaux la première expérience
c'était dans un aéroport où ils ont
demandé à 204 voyageurs ou est-ce qu'ils
allaient en voyage donc d'abord les gens
devaient dire la vérité parfois il fait
mentir ils ont analysé ces données par
rapport aux mouvements des regards
prédit en pnl et les résultats sont très
clairs ils sont pas significatifs c'est
à dire qu'il y avait tellement peu de
différence ça revenait à jouer une pièce
pile ou face au hasard pour donner la
réponse dans la deuxième expérience un
peu plus intéressante il y trente et une
personnes participant qui devait dire
quels métiers l'elysée après devait
mentir en s'inventant un métier sur ses
trente et une personnes 10% des
résultats repus être prédits par les
mouvements oculaires de la pnl 10% là
c'est significatif mais c'est pas vous
en conclusion moi je mange clairement du
côté des études scientifiques sur
l'analyse globale du schéma de la pnl
qu'on peut prendre froid s'est jeté à la
poubelle mais attention en prenant en
compte qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de
choses à voir au niveau des yeux par
contre commander sur cette chaîne je
suis et pourquoi on se refait pas une
expérience mentale comme on l'a fait
déjà deux fois cette année et ensuite je
publie les résultats alors encore une
fois on n'est pas dans un laboratoire
ici donc je publie les résultats mais
ils valent ce qu'ils valent
on n'est pas sûr que vous quand vous
répondez vous n'êtes pas déjà en train
de mentir on n'en sait rien chaque fois
que j'ai fait ça sur la chaîne vous avez
été trente mille quarante mille une fois
cinquante mille à participer donc c'est
intéressant je vous propose simplement
de demander à une personne de votre
entourage ce qu'elle fait dans la vie de
vous le raconter et vous notez qu'elle
est la direction principale de son
regard par rapport à elle c'est à dire
est ce que les yeux vont sur sa gauche
ou sur sa droite
sans chercher à penser au bas etc et
ensuite comme dans l'étude dont je vous
ai parlé vous lui demandez de s'inventer
un métier de vous raconter ce métier
qu'elle s'invente et là aussi vous notez
la dir
du regard et vous cliquez dans la
description il ya un lien un formulaire
où vous pouvez mettre votre résultat
j'analyserai toutes ces données et je
vous ferai une vidéo retour là dessus au
mois de septembre courant septembre
comme ça vous avez tout l'été pour faire
ça même si vous voulez le faire
plusieurs fois plusieurs personnes en
parlant de cet été y aura pas d'autres
dédicace cet été du livre les dédicaces
reprendront à partir du mois de
septembre je ne sais pas encore quand je
ne sais pas encore où j'ai vu un
commentaire pas c'est pas mal de fois
oui si vous avez déjà le livre je vous
le dédicace quand même y'a pas de soucis
et si vous l'avez pas votre cerveau est
extraordinaire il ya un lien sur une
vidéo explicative sur le livre dans la
description et maintenant qu'est ce
qu'on fait je vais vous le dire mais
qu'est ce qu'on fait on prend deux côtés
on met un petit truc dans son agenda
on se le marque en gros quelque part
dans la maison mais on prend rendez vous
là vous et moi oui toi qui regarde cette
vidéo je vous donne rendez vous pour la
prochaine vidéo à 11 heures samedi matin
comme d'habitude n'oubliez pas vous
pouvez mettre quelque chose en l'air et
merci de ne pas isoler cette phrase de
son contexte vous abonner si vous n'êtes
pas abonné ou que youtube vous à des
abonnés de la chaîne et rendez vous
samedi à 11h ciao
[Musique]